this man had a heck of a report
yesterday that caused me to say let's
get him on this show
i always want him on this show but this
one in particular about brian flores
there were elephants in the room and
dolphins in the room
yesterday apparently um talking about
the watson trade for draft picks but not
for two uh so many questions
about this jeff darlington of espn back
here in the ritual show how are you jeff
what's going on rich always a pleasure
always a pleasure talking to you all
right so
walk me through what happened uh in the
dolphins locker room best you can tell
yesterday
well
pretty simple rich um and and
how we interpret it uh which we will
certainly try to do is probably more
complex but
in its simplest form brian flores went
into his
team meeting at 4 pm a day ago and
he addressed he did something that he
doesn't normally do he addressed the
reports
that have tied the miami dolphins to
trade for deshaun watson with his
players and his staff present
and he did so by keeping it pretty brief
but also being pretty poignant and
saying that to a ton of vailoa is our
quarterback
um you know
that's so that's it that's end of story
that's what he did
i guess the question then becomes of
course why is that important
and my biggest takeaway from it
is
that this is not the same as cam newton
saying after they draft mack jones cam
newton is our quarterback only to a few
months later
bill belichick
waving cam newton it's not the same to
me as cliff kingsbury saying josh rosen
is our quarterback right now and the
difference is those were being said
in press conferences this was a head
coach standing in front of his players
where his integrity and his honesty is
is more important than anywhere else
telling them that two is our quarterback
i don't know i'm not saying it has
anything to do with what has happened or
what will happen but at this moment
flora's made clear that tua is his guy
well the reason why
that's important in in my mind
first thing i thought of when i read
your tweet on that and read
and heard your reporting on it jeff
is that the coach had to have
heard enough i'm out of saying brian
flores is out there watching
you know the rich eisen show get up
sports center nfl total access you know
i'm i'm not saying that but enough had
to have reached his ear gate to use the
miami of the miami uh legend michael
irvin's phrase
to to feel compelled to address it with
his team gather around
and maybe some of that chatter was in
his own locker room and he felt the need
to have to just put it to bed because
they've got to face bill belichick in a
week and a half
that's right and and honestly it it
sometimes i think when coaches do
put their head in the sand
they're forgetting that the players in
their locker room are smarter more aware
then then maybe they realize of course
players in that locker room including by
the way tua
had to
know what was scrolling out there and
one of the things that i made clear on
twitter and have in subsequent reports
is that this is not intended what i'm
saying here is not intended to dispute
for instance what charles robinson
someone who i respect greatly and have
known for a long time
what he reported
it's it's these two things are not
mutually exclusive i i believe that
that
flores going in there and saying to is
our quarterback
is not an indication
that the dolphins were not and perhaps
in the future will not be interested in
trading for deshaun watson
but rather to your point
look we're less than two weeks before
the start of the season
and
if you've got your quarterback and the
people around him
wondering
what the head coach thinks about him you
got to address it and he did just that
and i give him credit for it and i give
him credit for that and the question
does beg though jeff darlington based on
all this is why
the dolphins
still
were tire kicking
on yes a supremely
top three potentially top five talent at
the most important position
in not just the national football league
but maybe all professional team sports
got it but it's not just that alone all
things are not equal with desean watson
and for them to tire kick on that
mere weeks days if you want to put it
before a regular season
and think that it's not going to get out
because you also have to wonder
you can't you also have to wonder why
they would do that because you know
there are other teams in on it
and you know you can't guarantee other
teams certainly if i was another team in
on it and then
didn't get the guy but the dolphins were
i would totally leak it just to throw
that
grenade into the dolphins locker room
before the season absolutely why would
they do it
why would they do it
so
two things there
the why i think you answered
in in the way you sort of introduced
desean watson's resume in terms of being
a generational talent a top player at a
position that's the most
most important position in sports
the
the problem with that is so that's why
it makes sense
if there is any sense to be made of this
why an nfl team a coach anybody whoever
it was within the dolphins organization
would would be willing to to pursue and
kick those tires
i think oftentimes as we've seen so many
different times look i covered the
dolphins for years i remember when
jeff ireland got on a plane i was
covering the team at the time with
steven ross to fly across the country
and interview jim harbaugh while tony
sperano was still his coach and was
surprised when that ultimately got out
like sometimes
you dangle a carrot in front of these
teams and they don't necessarily think
about
the crisis management that comes the
repercussions that come with those
actions in this case
you're absolutely right um
there is so much more to desean watson
than his resume uh so the why
the only thing i can tell you is that
the why there be interest is that we're
talking about a generational player and
football teams whenever they have an
opportunity to look at a player like
that
they often cannot help but do it jeff
darlington of espn here on the rich
eisen show and again in light of the
fact that the head coach of the miami
dolphins felt compelled
to gather the team together uh based on
your report that that
that they gathered the team together to
say that the quarterback is is their guy
right
that that's not optimum that's not what
you want obviously ever just a couple
weeks before the season right that said
what what if it had worked
what if the trade had worked
what what was the then what for the
dolphins like what was that then what
that was my that was my big question all
along i couldn't and and maybe it's not
fair i mean maybe it is fair i don't
know i don't know where we're at with
this but like
to me
sitting there saying what happens if you
do make that trade you have to in the
building you haven't decided what's
going to happen to him the next day
there's a grand jury indictment deshaun
watson goes on the commissioner's exempt
list and you're looking back at two of
saying hey bud
you uh you want to hop in there take
some steps
like i can't i don't know maybe there's
more of a plan there you know whatever
the case
i i guess at this point
we're supposed to simply say
and i'm not sure what's fair and what's
not
that it didn't happen so we don't have
to cross that bridge
but i'm with you there were certainly a
lot of questions that would have come
along with it yeah i mean
you you pointed out the grand jury
aspect of it but the the more likely
result
over the next couple of weeks and months
is one that the texans are going to have
to now deal with which is probably why
they were trying to get him off their
roster right is is is that this thing
would have hovered and that you know
where the texans aren't starting him
they might what's the word for kesha on
him i don't know if that still is is is
the proper word for it just put him on
the shelf somehow right put him on the
shelf somehow like right
the dolphins would have done that and
still tua would have had to get in there
or they would have started him right and
then and then and then what so even if
you get through the season and the the
questions of why are you starting him
like what happened he'd be out in front
of a press conference something like
that and then or or even crazier you
start him you get through all of that
you win and then 2022 he's not your guy
because of all this stuff coming out of
nowhere i i i still i just can't compute
and i know we're we're we're moving on
and we will because there's a big
dolphins you know patriots game
uh the alabama bowl tour versus mac but
i still i still just can't move on yet
because i still
we're we're your reporting is about
the aftermath of it not happening what
would have been the aftermath of it
happening i still yeah maybe maybe maybe
it's and i'm not trying to be by any
means
i'm not trying to excuse them or
anything like that but i guess the one
thing i would say
in the defense of of the dolphins
is that they could have made the trade
and did not and perhaps that's
ultimately the reason they didn't right
was they looked at that and said well we
really this this really doesn't make a
lot of sense to which you would say
wouldn't you sort of be proactive in
that planning realize that not
you know even pursue it the point where
other teams find out and it gets leaked
out that i think sometimes is the type
of
do we call it crisis management that you
should we should think about as teams
before you engage in these actions but i
think it is at least fair to say
we can't crucify them
for something they ultimately decided
not to do
you can you can say hey
my only thing here is like
if you're brian flores and you're upset
about the quote-unquote distraction that
annoys me a little bit when you see him
called a distraction well that's
self-imposed
you know that that that is created by
actions it's not like
i i could say stephen ross the report
that came out that stephen ross was
driving the train that's a distraction
because i'm
fully confident based on conversations i
had before yesterday that that was not
the case that stephen ross is not
sitting here pounding the table for
desean watson
that i guess could be but otherwise
distractions are often self-imposed
jeff darlington here on the rich eisen
show that's an excellent point that i
personally i'll be honest i didn't think
of that that that trade was there on the
table and the dolphins just said we
don't want it although
uh word is that the texans still
refused to have pick protections
for the the acquirer of of desean watson
which is
nuts like that's here's a woman
if if
let's take away
the elephant in the room with deshaun
watson which is the 22 civil lawsuits
what what would a team i mean a team
would give up three first-round picks
and two second-round picks and a
heartbeat of course but desean watson
might not be made well desean watson
would have been available because of the
circumstances on the ground between
mid-january through the first allegation
to be made public right so i'm sorry i
mean interrupted what happened this the
deal would have happened before the
draft but it honestly probably would
have been five first-round picks
for a generational quarterback so maybe
these teams are simply saying
we could potentially get
desean watson at a deal
once again though the problem with that
is
the conditions that that deal comes with
i mean
it's like buying a
car that you can't even look at and you
know i don't know just it just doesn't
feel safe doesn't feel smart well then
let me leave it with this with you with
one last question jeff darlington let's
talk about the elephant that's still in
the room
based on last year's performances of
herbert and tua the fact that tua is not
the best quarterback in that draft and
will never be
and the dolphins already know that the
guy that they fell in love with when he
looked off for safety for alabama in a
national championship game isn't that
guy and that's what they believe and
that's why they're tire kicking a guy
with more baggage than lax
right now
um despite his incredible talent just a
couple weeks before the season what what
about that
well and that's that that is where i
think you get into perhaps the
contentious conversation internally
which is
who is to uh
what is his value and is he our
franchise leader
there are people that that you know the
wild part about this not to not to turn
this into what fans think because as
much as i love fans
their opinions don't you know careful
don't go javi baez on me don't go there
don't twitch there don't go please it's
a thumbs up show jeff go for it i'm only
going to say that these
i i have never i live in south florida
i've been down here for 15 years yes
i've not seen the type of support
that has
followed to uh
um
despite what i would call a pretty
mediocre rookie season
i totally get what you're saying about
justin herbert
and by the way joe burrow who's somehow
been suddenly forgotten because of a
knee injury
uh
but they could have gotten herbert they
couldn't get
but for what there are people in the
building who truly believe that too it
just needs some time to develop
and he needs at least another season to
prove that so
while i get what you're saying and
clearly there are some questions based
on the actions of the organization
uh i i
there are still those who believe that
two will ultimately be the franchise guy
and by the way
what about that story
if
after this offseason what's happened to
uh goes in there and proves that he is
in fact
a franchise quarterback for the miami
dolphins jeff what a great chat i knew
it would be as always greatly
appreciated let's get you back on it uh
let's get you back on every uh every so
often look for my call please rich thank
you man you bet that's jeff darlington
of espn formerly my colleague at the uh
nfl media group
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here